hey guys welcome back to reality check
the game spot sure that teaches us to
love laugh learn and of course love on
this week's love lecture animal murder
or more to the point using animals to
murder yeah he's just so adorable but is
all this weaponizing of animals actually
a real thing well it's time to dig into
the past and present to find out just
how close this animal a deed anarchy is
to real life now sure using animals as
weapons in video games is really nothing
new exploiting terrifying ferocious
deadly beasts to gain the upper hand in
battle is something we've seen time and
time again although on some occasions I
must say it can be hard to stomach
the Far Cry series has done this before
too though when playing three I
regularly unleash Tigers to help capture
outposts cause a distraction and just
generally Paul my enemies to death
however Ubisoft really seem to have
doubled down on weaponizing animals in
Far Cry 4 so much though that the
centerpiece of their showing at this
year's Sony e3 press conference was
arguably this ferocious and decidedly
explosion-proof elephant but you know
what the Far Cry team didn't just make
this all up well maybe they're surviving
the explosion bit but they're using the
elephant in battle there
oh no that's a very real thing from very
real history mention of war elephants
can be found in historical texts from as
early as the 4th century BC and almost
certainly originated in India were
spreading it across Southeast Asia and
also west toward the Mediterranean their
main use in battle was to charge at the
enemy breaking the ranks generally
trampling their way through and scaring
the living bejesus out of anyone still
dumb enough to be standing there there's
even record of war elephants being
outfitted with weapons and armor to
specifically heavy iron chains with
steel balls at the end tied to their
trunks the animals were then strained to
swirl them around like some sort of
gigantic Morning Star but you know
elephants aren't the only animals who
have been weaponized in times of war I
tell you what let's have a quiz a world
exclusive it's time for the first-ever
and probably last ever game of
no wait I've got a better one don't
worry it's easy all you need to do is
guess which option is an actual animal
that's been used in war and which one is
just a creature you can find in Far Cry
4 let's give it a go the answer is
dolphins not killer dolphins mind you
know the United States marine mammal
program recruits bottlenose dolphins and
also California sea lions to help find
and ultimately dispose of underwater
mines they are taught to search specific
areas for objects notify the trainer's
if they find something and then deploy a
marking beacon so the disposal team can
dive down and do their part the programs
days do appear to be numbered however as
the use of live mammals is due to come
to a close in 2017 as they replaced by
robotic mine finders
it's pigeons meet Olga of Kiev she was
the ruler and regent of Kiev and roofs
back in the 9th century AD her kingdom
was made up of parts of modern-day
Ukraine Belarus and Russia and Olga was
kind of a real-life Queen Cersei every
part is ruthless as she was cunning when
it came to defending her son's rights to
sit upon the throne when her enemies
tried to steal her son's birthright by
forcibly marrying her she proceeded to
take hostage of the ten would-be suitors
and bury them alive not in pidgins mind
you that'd be weird
no no she used pigeons to burn down an
entire city how well whilst laying siege
to her enemies last stronghold by way of
tribute she demanded each household give
her three pigeons and three sparrows she
then commanded her soldiers to attach
sulphur bound in cloth to the feet of
the birds and then released them back
into the city the birds then returned to
their homes the sulphur ignited and the
whole place was set ablaze
now while the story is fantastic I'm a
little skeptical mainly because sulphur
shouldn't just ignite to anything under
230 degrees Celsius even in powder form
then I guess with enough friction it
could easily spark up but I really see
how that could happen other than maybe
some very vigorous pigeon mating avian
sex aside though during World War two
the United States genuinely considered a
modern-day equivalent of this tactic
against the Japanese instead of pigeons
and sulphur however they went for bats
and timed incendiary explosives they
were actively tested with optimistic
results but were never actually used the
u.s. famously relied on something
altogether more terrifying
[Music]
yep man's best friend has also played
his part in wars throughout history
Henry the eighth actually famously gave
a gift of 400 Mastiffs to the king of
Spain who then used them on mass in
battles against the French can you
imagine a pack of 400 masters charging
at you
these guys can weigh up to 60 pounds and
grow canine teeth up to two and she's
long pretty effective I'd wager but dogs
have also been deployed in conflicts
much more recently than that in World
War two the Russians used dogs as
anti-tank weapons against the German
armor although the original plan had
been to train the dogs to drop the
explosives and then returned to their
masters
this tactic routinely failed and was
replaced by an impact detonation
procedure which obviously killed a dog
in the process while on that depressing
note it's time to end the quiz and also
this week's reality check let me know
your score and also what animals you'd
like to see in Far Cry 4 by dropping me
a comment down below or by getting in
touch on Twitter at Camp frass Rob now
personally I've got my fingers crossed
for sharks with frickin laser beams on
their heads and also dogs with bees in
their mouths and when they bark they
shoot easy oh and if you want more
informed far cry 4 and also more of my
face why not check out the stage demo I
hosted at e3 a few weeks ago with
executive producer Dan hey okay thanks
for watching folks see you next week
[Music]